[Music]
like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Tuesday hope you enjoyed a nice
long weekend drinking some claw hittin
the beach final weekend of summer I'm so
excited for fall but my big white legs
away it's gonna be happy September do
you remember the two anodize that we
were just talking about how September
really has changed for me over the years
and I'm assuming for everyone because it
used to be like this time of year was so
anxiety-inducing counting down the days
like three more days your school
supplies yeah that was actually the only
good part of my reading done you know
then you like read the CliffsNotes
something summery you don't even do that
you just read the back of the book and
I've been out of school for what feels
like you know a millennium but Snitch
this is your first September not be
going back to school yeah how do you
feel it's honestly an amazing feeling
like some of my friends went back today
Oh like I'm not jealous of you with your
backpack and your like pencil I'm like
adults always like to tell you like
enjoy still sharpen they always say like
enjoy school like the real world sucks
like no [ __ ] way nothing the real
world throws to me it's nearly as bad as
writing a paper i completely agree
i completely share and like some people
would disagree with that but personally
blanket statement of like enjoy school
you know these are the best times it
doesn't apply to everyone so like stop
putting the fear of god and these
students like let them get excited i
just want to say that like the real
world pretty cool yeah it's not as bad
as it says you know yes I got them suits
anyone uses the word of don't thing you
can't handle it oh my god there's a
special place in how far it was whoever
created that word because it's made a
bunch of loser Millennials know and also
it's now being abused by Gina Gershon
himer oh my god but I'll start going to
adult give to kids like it's not funny
anymore two words that should not be
used as verbs adult in and summer Inc
oh I couldn't agree more driving even
though we were summering hard this week
only summer
so hard it was summer nights y'all it's
summer nights no oh wow um we went to
see Rascal Flatts in Dallas on Friday
night and I'm not gonna lie I was tired
you know I was super exhausted we had
flown in that morning it was just like
I'm supposed to have vacation and I was
like tired the whole time and even the
spirit of running into toasters like it
could not resuscitate me like yeah I was
beyond resuscitation and I told her the
spirit of the rascals they'll take you
away you don't need you come with
nothing and I said okay I mean I don't
believe you because I'm like as a human
being genuine generally like immune to
resuscitate you think if I'm tired I
need to go home but all of a sudden I
hear boom rascal all I know
I couldn't stop sweating I was up I was
dancin I was livid Bing yeah I literally
lost my mind at this concert like we
were dancing so hard we were in our
seats like going ham and then some
toasters let us know the security guard
was trying to get our attention to bring
us down to the pit because he and then
when we finally went he was like I've
been trying to get your attention for an
hour like oh she's come over to us then
he couldn't leave his post she's trying
to do us a favor and he's gonna lose his
job
well the pig was just [ __ ] magical
usually I don't like a pet because I
enjoy a chair but I wasn't even using my
chair in my seats right so we got to the
pit and then there was more room to
dance there was more room to make eye
contact with the rascals where I mr.
rascal himself Gary said I see you to us
because um we had met him at the
meet-and-greet which is where this story
gets a little sad but wait when he made
the eye contact did you think that was
with us or like just with me no with us
because we had told him women at the
mean greet we're gonna need the girls in
the front mercy right and then finally
an hour later we were yeah and so like
if anyone it was to me that's just like
so greasy like we're writing like no
because like I literally like had this
moment with Gary three and I was like I
know like you were like getting in on it
and I was like it's like let her have it
you know it was like 100% like I was
ratings big neon [ __ ] dress I was as
big as a bard like there was no way he
was like he was like it was a your dress
that got his attention for me things and
it was just like you know sighs you know
I designed it
super super cute it was a brightness but
it was like this moment between me and
Carrie and then I let you in on it
towards the end we're like the moment
was definitely initiated by Gary for me
I was the girl on the camera so you were
behind me and that it was totally mine
but for the sake of just like I don't
want you to feel so bad about yourself
so like you could say that I mean I
don't it was the second time this summer
that he recognized me so it's fine
oh did he recognize you from the PNC no
no so we went to the meet-and-greet
amazing we got our photos with the
Rascals then the men came they got we
got a family so doing Zack and Beth yeah
and then they got their own photo and we
were like so excited feeling good all in
all we took like six pictures like me
and Jackie all of us the boys like we
took a million pictures and we are still
waiting for so like we were checking the
meet-and-greet website all the time our
pictures never went out our concert was
8:30 and down the pictures from the next
night went up like this at least get
dark we're refreshing refreshing 8:29
Sugarland Texas and we keep refreshing
and nothing's coming up between h1 we're
830 Dallas next thing I know 831
Cincinnati so like our pictures are lost
what pictures are lost and that's what
that's the curse of my life oh that okay
that's not bad
maybe something worse that is bad we got
to the concert like six hours early just
to meet the Restless memories yeah I
just mean it was cool to meet em but we
weren't able to take our own photos so
like I get gallery ever does like this
rascal flat like meet-and-greet you know
I'm there was a man with a camera like
please that's whatever interns
responsibility is to get it up like I
beg of you I beg of you to find the cop
it's too important to too many people it
really is and not just us like everyone
who walked out of the meat and green was
in such high spirits oh cool and like
all of those people are now depressed
Gary is just like such a cutie like I
love him the lead singer of rascal pop
they're just they're so talented if you
have the opportunity at two a rascal
hearts concert please please go if you
have any inclination towards country
music and this this tour is like their
summer playlist source so they're not
touring a new album they're literally
just playing the protest which is really
all we want yeah you know great
not from Nashville she went to snatch it
are you okay no I'm not okay thus
Nashville Nashville snatched my spirit
where did you say my back people are
wanting your recommendation so where did
you say I stayed at the Omni thanks to a
recommendation from my sisters it was
great great location it was like
literally a block away from Broadway
like so I sadly had to walk everywhere
but well it's a too convenient
convenient and also there's so much
traffic on Broadway that like taking an
uber would have made it absolutely no
sense yeah it was amazing I let's give
you a rundown of my weekend we got there
we friend thing you went with today all
like like country music
so Nicole absolutely loves country music
Lauren has just started like in country
music Rebecca was the one who does not
like country music but she knew she was
not allowed to complain whereas we were
going to Nashville right in the pub
right yeah exactly
so she was she was a trooper and she
didn't really complain once she just
made us play motivation by normanni like
once a day and I think that sounds
really growing on me yeah yeah me too so
we did that we got to the hotel lovely
we were very surprised it was a
ginormous hotel like it was like a big
you know it's like attention yeah and
the Country Music Hall of Fame is inside
how we got in with like you'd have to go
outside which I loved because there's
hot as balls and now she yeah
we went to the palm for dinner because
it was Shabbat to me I've been there too
yeah and it was the closest dinner place
and Lauren couldn't drive and whatever
it was really nice it's really nice
except we kind of felt like a fish out
of water cause like when there was like
with your outfits
yeah it was weird everyone was staring
so then we just hit Broadway hit all the
places we literally each night went to
like six bars the stage became our home
not I we tried to make legends our home
it just like didn't we didn't have a
legendary different vibe every night
right hit sometimes right and the stage
hit every single night and it was just
epic
and that was amazing and then we were
like holy [ __ ] like this is what our
weekend's gonna be like we're not ready
then we went B when it came home after
everyone sleep whatever went to Pinewood
social for dinner brunch because that's
what everyone said to do especially
Lauren Bushnell who did a Nashville
guide thing like she did as an ad but
I've used it and it was on there and
everyone was telling its mean it was so
cool was like literally was like a bar
patio but then they
had a pool in the back and then also
like a really nice huge restaurant and
thing that's so great about Nationals
there's so much space so all the
restaurants are so big and so nice and
air conditioning they really respect the
hell out of air conditioning there so
that was great and then we went to
Country Music Hall of Fame which I loved
I think my friends probably like thought
it was torture but for me it was great
and then went to a museum I know it's
like such a weird thing for like a world
wanted to do it I was in the hotel and
also it's like it's sick yeah it was
[ __ ] also it was Shabbat too like we
were couldn't like really do anything
like so far away so you're just trying
to figure out you know make everyone
happy and then Saturday night Saturday
night oh my god we had the most amazing
meal of my life it's like actually one
of the best at Kane Prime it was just
like the most amazing meal they had this
crispy rice oh it was insane we got - it
was amazing just the food was amazing
just high spirits that was really the
key to the weekend with spirits being
super high and then you know we just
same old Broadway blah blah blah and
then Sunday was the best day of my life
when we did the honky Tonk Express oh
that's so fun oh my god
like I just it was iconic it was the
greatest weekend of my life I actually
can't even stress that enough
well I'm happy for your book Jackie and
I had a seven-layer pudding
oh we had a seven-layer paying that
snatchler you would have loved it it was
like a layer of chocolate cake vanilla
pudding Oreo chocolate pudding [ __ ]
whipped cream it was so good did you
make it we had to one of the seas this
place said Jackie wanted me to go to and
I was it was straight from the airport
and like if you know when you're feeling
like if I don't get a morsel food into
my mouth like I could shoot this place
up like that's how crazy hungry I was
and they were taking forever to make the
food and then they were giving out
samples of this pudding and Jackie
brought me went over and like literally
if you've never been more grateful to be
your sister in that moment because first
of all it was my sense so [ __ ] good
second of all it was like a heaping like
it was a big sample size I think it
wasn't usually it's like in New York
it's like a bite-size no this was like a
scoop yeah and I had three and then we
bought the big container for the house
and we ate it like on Saturday again
brought us joy every turn since she can
meet a cowboy the toasters want to know
I didn't meet a cowboy but like their
works it was crawling with Cowboys that
we kept saying I was like I've never
seen so many hot guys in one place it
was wild also because there was a huge
football game that really was
encroaching on our team about games
everywhere it was so annoying it was
just in
dated with Georgia Georgia everywhere
like I went to a bar and the whole place
was red because that's their color it's
so fun it would nose cuz like all these
people went to college together and it
was like weird I felt like I was at a
frat house and then I wasn't invited
yeah well also special episode Shay we
have Amanda Stanton joining us later
today I'm so excited it's been a while
since she's been on the show so many
questions to ask her there's a new book
coming out that I believe it's quite
delicious so I'm looking forward to
finding out you know what it's about I
read it yeah you need the cliff notes
yes as you know I don't like to read I
am gonna read it because I love a
Bachelor memoir and it's been a long
time since we got one yeah
I'm also the bachelor in paradise first
episode of the week was on last night
and normally we like to like discuss
before we do a full episode that's not
sure but it was honestly the worst
episode I've ever seen that I literally
have nothing to say I mean watch it yeah
it's so bad but hopefully tomorrow
tonight will be better it looks better
yeah I mean mustache etc it's natural
recording tomorrow actually around 1 2
o'clock would you say yeah yeah you know
sometimes a little earlier crazy
and speaking of premium content we
posted our toast radio episode on Friday
and I have to say like 3 to Zurich the
world by storm reviews are in and
they're good yes like it's everyone's
favorite episode it will definitely
become a monthly installment and if
you're looking for some more premium
content today head over to patreon.com
slash the morning toast now I feel as
though it is time to deliver the past 5
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast is that fine a scribe is
like if you know it's fine alright I
mean it's not great because it would be
great if you would let me let everyone
know that today's episode is brought to
you by vistaprint I will not stop yeah
miss su print uses only carefully
selected inks and responsibly sourced
paper stocks for your business cards if
you're starting a business you're an
influencer you're the blog I don't know
whatever it is that you do I don't know
what people outside like if you host a
podcast called with Sanja you need new
business cards with like roses all over
it I didn't even have an old one okay
it's just it's it's an important staple
of every business woman no it is and
like until someone asks you do you have
a business card and you don't have one
like you'll never know how to shave a
piece of [ __ ] you are and like the
missed opportunity mhm
Justin's up designs that are just right
for your business so you can upload your
own design with Jackie made the mistake
of doing ones or they have like fancy
designs or
that you could just like input your
information you can add your logo your
contact information with just a few
clicks and now you can use it on all
your marketing going forward your
satisfaction is 100% guaranteed or
Vistaprint we'll make it right either by
reprinting your order or offering you a
refund mr. Brent wants you to be able to
own the now in any situation which is
why our listeners will get 500 high
quality custom business cards starting
at $9.99 use code toast at
vistaprint.com that's code TOA st at
vistaprint.com toast at vistaprint.com
sign on and get your [ __ ] together sign
on be professional yes
okay first story it's just some
wonderful beautiful loose about two
beautiful people because Kelly's ferry
and miles teller are married it's
beautiful I mean I'm green with envy I'm
like everything every bit of it
everything first of all that body
[ __ ] snatched away the spatulas Nats
higher that waistline snatch I thought
she's wearing a corset like no she just
looks like those legs in her shirt yeah
she's dancing Chicago that husband that
husband that after-party those arms her
sister's like they're so close I believe
her sister planned the wedding
teaching I think her sister had a heavy
hand yeah I just like oh I'm sorry and
then the most green with envy of it all
who sent her flowers Taylor Swift and I
such put up a picture of the card the
Taylor sent and is that from your friend
Taylor and I'm like oh I wonder like
what you have her friends that is but
then and then I'm reading the card and
it says may you always be this close
forever and ever and then that's what I
knew it was like the real teletype
though let me tell her that matters and
now instead of looking at the pictures
with happiness and joy I look at the
entire situation through an envious eye
the pictures are so beautiful they're so
they're invoke already goes like that
was her exclusive right up and it was so
beautiful they talked about how they met
at a Black Eyed Peas Black Keys [ __ ] you
oh it sounds like I peed milk black yes
very mainstream yeah a Black Keys party
and how he proposed in Africa and the
whole story is so [ __ ] cute and I'm
so happy for them I'm in the picture
happy Oh
she's the car the dress she had two
dresses and then changed into jobs for
the after party which kygo DJed which
just looked so [ __ ] fun yeah the
whole night looks perfect they are
perfect and I'm just I didn't know how
much I needed this wedding you know and
I'm so I didn't think we'd get any
content from it like I thought he'd be
so proud so I'd like the same exact
thing I was stalking I was on my taking
sacrum count watching all of her sisters
in scrim stories Nina Dobrev stroking
the Ritz Carlton kapalua like literally
everything just for a [ __ ] picture
hashtag it was one girl who obviously
broke the rule and put up an Instagram
story of Kelly and miles like walking
down the aisle leaving the ceremony but
I thought they were not gonna show us
anything and then like a month I'd be
like a month ago today is there so a
lists they don't have to show us
anything but I so appreciate the fact
that they understand like how much we
just wanted like bits and pieces and
then they got their like professional
photos turned around for Vogue in like
one day checky they're so fun they're so
devoted to premium content well whilst
also being a listen I don't know of
another couple out there that can do
both no and it doesn't seem like tacky
like they're just like young and fun and
so cool like they know everyone just
like wants to be there who's the
coolness yeah like I'm sure their
pictures didn't even need an edit that's
why they're so [ __ ] handsome and
perfect and he shamed fir'd wedding
thank God my idea of a mustache yeah
yeah and let's talk about celebrities in
attendance nina dobrev which we knew
because her and Kelly are best friends
and they she was on the bachelor party
really you know out of left field to
shailene woodley yep what movie did they
do together at like everything not like
the one one that's running their wipers
away divergent oh yeah one of those that
we did what's it George Clooney one
conversion oh the George Clooney one
when they're in like in Hawaii but it's
like a spectacular now is the one with
miles teller shailene woodley I know
what's the movie with shailene woodley
and George Clooney
I'm always referencing this movie and I
can never remember and they live in
Hawaii is it with Britt Robertson also I
don't know the descendents yes I knew it
was gonna say descendants but then you
guys were gonna be like it's a Disney
movie
got it oh it's like descendants
divergent convergent isn't it wholesales
the descendants isn't part of it but he
miles teller shailene Woodley's
divergent insurgent and it's really cute
that they were there she wasn't wearing
shoes and I just was wondering if that
was like a her thing or like a wedding
Hawaii I think it's a wedding
like it she's like you know she doesn't
eat anything besides like milk you know
who shailene woodley she lives on a farm
I know I actually speaking of her I'm
one episode away from finishing big
little i/o I started in the first three
episodes a big little lies on the plane
to and from Dallas and I couldn't
[ __ ] hear anything cuz I got the
cheap-ass headphones oh that sucks it
sucked so I need to like rewatch the
three episodes but you know what you
haven't missed anything also this isn't
a spoiler if you've already watched
three episodes but like all it is is
like dealing with the open ends from
season one where but the way season 1
and it was so nice and you could just
imagine that they all got to a good
place afterwards but now it's like no I
have to deal with the consequences of
season embody bringing everyone down get
over I love Bonnie yeah but but get over
it are you I don't love Bonnie get over
it I love those shoes this season before
you yeah no I'm saying on her back no
she's not she's she's taking it on her
back like and she won't tell her husband
she's ruining her whole life for the
team she didn't even like these stitches
that's true you know but she is the one
who pushed him right because like no she
wasn't mine like [ __ ] being [ __ ] nosy
no she was the one who pushed him
because like she's a woman who supports
other women we inevitably said that's
what I thought too but like Nicole
Kidman the way she's talking about peri
like in oh yeah it's like we were very
violent and we sucked and I liked it and
now it seems like she misses him so
what's he an abuser or like or did you
like it right and the way season 1 ended
it's like finally she's liberated but
then in season 2 I guess they had to
make some [ __ ] up and it's like no it's
not good at all like the parry dying was
like such a blessing in the end it
solved every single problem but it's
like no now there's the problems [ __ ]
this
no but like living for the relationship
between Nicole Kidman and shailene
woodley like sisters and arms whose kids
are both bothered by like this
incredible rapist yeah totally I am here
for the the feminist of them from that
angle I know and I'm actually really
loving Grenada this season oh by the way
laura dern when she's talking about oh
she's in the cover of a magazine and
then delivery cousin gets arrested five
seconds later Laura Dern is the greatest
actress of our generation is so insane
she's insane and like you could tell if
she actually must be a lot like Renata
because I've seen her and she was in the
founder like I've seen her and stuff
before and I never thought her to me
such a
selling actress but the way she just you
know portrays Renata means that they're
the exact same Nelson just we're not as
such a compelling woman it's like in one
scene she'll literally be like shepherd
wife toast of the town and then she's
like so sad and yeah I'm worried about
her dog like and her projection on
Arabella
her projection onto her daughter like I
feel so bad for this kid well okay now
I'm kind of feeling like I want to
finish it so okay yeah and I'm gonna
finish it she started the act the Gypsy
Rose Blanchard who Lulu because they had
a gun tail to to and I just want to say
like very mad Joey King does an
incredible job and that shouldn't be
lost over like how she portrays this
like very strange girl but I don't know
it's like it's such an interesting story
like the mom faked the kids thing and
then she killed them up it's so
interesting and I found myself being so
bored by Jerry that they made it like
they dredged out they slowed it down but
that if you feel robbed of it all I know
interested buzz he like did a whole
article on this story before it was made
into a movie and that's what I read and
I feel caught up yeah like it isn't it
it's an interesting I do the story at
all so that by watching it that's how I
learned it but I could have easily have
read nerd they somehow found a way to
make it dragged out boring that's what
they do
speaking of shows i watch i watch all
seasons of all episodes of the hills new
beginnings oh and I have so many
thoughts because it's like weirdly so
person to situation Katelyn Brody
mmm-hmm I leave it on like you see if
the writing is on the wall and like as
suspected she is the perfect woman like
she's so beautiful she's so smart she
gives great advice she's a businesswoman
like she's everything and so I
understand why everyone is like
clamoring to be the most supportive of
Caitlyn right in the you know we're out
also I just want to say like Mischa
Barton is my favorite character which is
so she's actually not oh man
no because I was like what is she doing
on the show what is she doing in her
life who is she what is she doing she's
I'm so confusing but like she is like
has such a good head on her shoulders
she's such a good friend she's so
well-spoken and she like stands up for
herself she's just always on the right
side of history and like I just want the
best for her like she's so precious and
like I'm so mad at everyone who ever
hurt her that's okay and she's been so
hurt like yes yes
great I feel like she's got some stories
yeah I feel like she just [ __ ] it
spreads Hilton yeah oh my god and she
stood up to him and she was so
incredible and well-spoken and like put
him in his place and she's what also
sometimes people just like apologize and
you're like okay great but sometimes you
do it I'm not like I'm so pissed yeah
and so she was still nice and like he
wound up like exploding and showing his
true colors and like it was just it like
who
oh he's on it he was just in one episode
because him and her had beef because
like he was like the biggest bully I
remember what she farted in every single
day that's what he said
so evil he's evil oh my god I have to
watch that episode I need to see yeah so
it's just like eight there are moments
that are interesting for a show that
like Leona was kind of very scripted
rather like Stephanie Pratt is there's
so much going on there yeah off her
rocker okay maybe I'll watch it yeah I
was really surprised that I was so
interested in it what are we gonna for
lunch I'm starving I don't know honestly
like I not have actually after seeing
these pictures of Kelly Sperry at her
wedding I'm never eating again Oh
totally Oh back to Kelly Sperry miles
teller it Sochi pre-wedding abeer the
wedding of the year and I just I'm now
I'm ready for honeymoon pics me too I
feel like they're always on a honeymoon
yes they take a lot of trips they go to
one an only pom ELA that hotels like
everyone from LA goes to they go to
Hawaii a lot they go to Africa Safari
yeah I wonder what they're gonna do I
feel like they're gonna they'll probably
do something different now yeah but it's
a tough time because like the summer's
over so I thought everyone's gonna like
Italy and it's hurricane season so you
can't go to like the Bahamas or the
Caribbean I feel like I could see them
in Italy or maybe like Croatia
yeah okay yeah whatever it is I'll take
it whatever it is I'm so happy for them
like I truly wish I'm like a lifetime of
happening of happiness and like sincere
and genuine joy agreed okay and respect
you know mm-hmm and stability
next up Kevin Hart is recovering from
back surgery after a major car accident
so crazy like his wife said he's totally
fine but if you see pictures of a car
it's like no you're not yes it was able
to get out of the car once it wrecked
but um they said was seriously a major
accident so this is a miracle and there
were two other people on the car right
yeah his family trainer and I think
maybe the trainer's wife and she was
treated at the scene it was fine no the
trainer was the woman I thought oh
whatever
the woman was treated at the scene him
was fine I was
she was yeah and it's just so weird
because it's all very casual but the
cars are like completely destroyed and
it fell into a ditch like it wasn't just
like it bumped into something like it
really like tongues so scary
that's so scary I'm so happy everyone's
okay that's just like like terrible
accidents happening these days like left
and right mr. Wonderful's wife yeah yeah
that story like still shake me I know
and then there was do you see the other
boats story this weekend there was like
a boat that was that off the coast of
the West Coast that set on fire there
was like 35 yes and you were died yeah
really scary and it just set on fire
like on its own I don't know what the
mechanical issue was but this is I'm
saying that's sort of saying let's speak
like there's something about boats that
ain't right
you know yeah I'm gonna stay away not
that I like have a million offers to on
boats but you know if I do get an offer
I will say I will think twice and then
I'll get on again but yeah totally
but you'll have your lifejacket like
yeah of course no no and it's like I
keep now that there's like so much like
trauma happening like that's what like
this Chappell special was talking about
like so many school shootings that their
literary training kids and like what to
do like it's just to become so much a
part of our lives like these tragedies
like I really been starting to think
like what what kind of person do I want
to be like in in a dangerous situation
like to I wanna be a hero honestly no
like I'm in the [ __ ] out every man for
themselves right I'd like to think that
I'm like a brave enough person I feel
like you guys would like be a hero and
like scoop some kids up on my way but
honestly no I feel like actually
absolutely no one knows what kind of
person they're gonna be angry and the
person who thinks that they're gonna be
a hero is the biggest [ __ ] of them all
you know there's no like test you can
take that can tell you what you're gonna
be in that situation so true and that's
when you like scare people on the news
who like you know jumped in front of a
bullet or do something super brave
they're like I don't know what happened
but I think also some of it is just like
when you're in that situation like you
might have opportunities to help people
sometimes you don't like there's not a
logistics right you yeah somewhere you
go out of your way to be a hero put more
people in danger right but like maybe
you're right by the door and so like
what what are you gonna do in that
situation you need to like you're not
gonna start moving traffic they're out
there way you know when I used to take
the subway to high school I would always
say like someone on this train they
could just stab us all well you never
know
it's [ __ ] crazy and I'm gonna always
think I'm like I want to be a hero like
I'm gonna take him down I'm gonna cover
your oh my god and now I think back I'm
like no [ __ ] way look I have a family
I gotta get out of here no one like I
just feel as though you know if
someone's gonna take him down like it's
just not know it need not gonna be me
you know unless I could lure him away
with some of my snacks you know yeah but
you wouldn't even do that like and to
this [ __ ] no no [ __ ] way doesn't
deserve I'm what we hope Kevin Hart is
feeling okay very traumatic times in the
heart household yeah but I'm really
happy that you know this could have been
so much worse and it wasn't yeah I'm
sure he's feeling very blessed but if
you like a back injury is like bad
looking but all the injuries like neck
and back it's like the worst hit to get
back surgery mm-hmm
like that's bad no it's not good it's
not good but it's much worse getting
ankle surgery
yeah actually ankle is bad leg is easier
than ankle but I'll be back and neck are
like the worst cause it's not right next
story some exciting news Demi Lovato and
Taylor Swift are squashing their beef
because Demi stands um this article like
it needs to get a correction can you
read me the title again um I wasn't
gonna read the tale I was just gonna
read the entry of the title
why just I'll tell you why Demi Lovato
leaves Taylor Swift with the biggest
smile after praising lover album okay
cuz it's a day squash there because
there literally was no beef between
anyone except Demi and made up beef with
Taylor
Taylor's never even acknowledged gems
presence like please this is such
[ __ ] Demi like comes for Taylor all
the time for seemingly no [ __ ] reason
and naturally what squash and beans like
Taylor was like there wasn't any baby
yeah I'm on a totally different level
than you because they were friends and
then they were not friends but like
years ago like there has not been real
beef like for a while no but it's like
they just grew apart yeah I bet it ain't
really should be friends because Demi
could really use a stable person in her
life like Taylor who doesn't do drugs
yes uh yeah but like I think Demi Selena
Taylor's team Selena it's just not true
you know got about that yeah it's all
weird tests protection program yeah and
they were the best Barney they were the
best of friends yeah do you ever find
out what happened there I don't know so
so basically over the weekend
Demi Lovato put up a couple Instagram
stories that read she said life's too
short for women not to support other
women especially
released great music great job at Taylor
Swift and then posted krill her and then
Taylor Swift reposted her and said this
is so awesome and put the biggest smile
on my face thank you at Demi Lovato well
Taylor had to be gracious because
Taylor's whole brand is women supporting
women and this is a perfect example of
we a supporting women but it's just like
this whole like faked up like stirred up
drama between Demi and Taylor it's just
like not real like yeah I did like the
whole thing didn't seem real like I was
just like she could have honestly she
could have posted cruel summer without
saying anything else I would have
thought it was very oh I would have
thought it was the pewter Brown like
Demi was the most outspoken woman when
Taylor Swift posted the thing about
Scooter Braun so I I'm really I think
this is just great all around I do we
think great was great it's like weird
but if you would have asked me literally
a week ago like who are Taylor Swift's
like biggest enemies I would have seen I
said Kanye and Kim and like a few people
used to be Katy Perry literally devil
about it would never even cross my mind
because like that's not theirs because
they're beat like their rivalry like
Kimber scale or Kanye vs. Taylor Katy
Perry their songs written about it like
it's you know it's real arcs no it's
like huge her and Demi
I just think aren't each other's cup of
tea generally I think they're on two
totally different levels like they have
nothing in common
Demi's gonna date my child like Miley
Cyrus like they just have there's no
real beat thing where one's friends
they're not because they just have
nothing in common yeah but there has
been like a few things of Demi like
during Taylor's performance at the VMAs
like putting our instant I'm sorry it's
like I will never perform at the VMAs
and you can speculate why I'm just
saying whatever so you're saying there
is beef I'm just saying like Jimmy's
always [ __ ] like nipping at Taylor
I'm Tiller's like [ __ ] off I don't even
know who you are
I feel like Jimmy's always living at the
industry and Taylor is just like a
symptom of that no because Taylor is
also like anti industry they actually
should get along really well that's true
yeah maybe this is maybe this is the way
to do that I have something great maybe
also I think Jimmy's close with the
Kardashians like that's where she's
aligned
yes he loves supports the Kardashians
yeah oh he loves it but the magic word
rind
I maybe I read a blind that was like the
total opposite what
say like gem you defended one of the
Kardashians I think Kim as like a fellow
Kirby woman and like Kim camp like said
to know being like stop calling him that
I think it was like a really long time
ago but I remember being struck by that
mind interesting interesting Kim sent a
note or statement no no not a
publication like between friends oh
that's how it looked the blinds found
out about it you know okay anyways I
thought this was all great news I'm glad
that like whoever's just bringing people
together you know it was great news but
you know I'm just I'm wary I'm
protective of Taylor that's it okay
that's all I think like I think Demi
Lovato's talks a lot of shape and then
she's also the first person to like own
up to it and she wasn't like extending
an olive branch here and I think she
dishes it out but she can take it and
I'm glad Taylor reciprocated it yeah
yeah and that it's all good technically
it's all good yeah yeah this is it's
like not that they're gonna get back to
having sleepovers right it's all surface
level anyway the surface was bad now the
surface is good um before we continue I
would just like to give me a moment to
our sponsors to its episode's sponsored
by modern fertility the first
comprehensive fertility hormone test for
women that you can take it home we're
waiting longer to have kids because
we've got stuff to do
but it's posing a problem because one in
six couples have trouble conceiving we
all have the tools to prevent pregnancy
but we need more information on how to
help us plan for it even if kids are in
the far far future modern fertility
gives you customized reports to help you
understand your fertility through your
hormones you'll have a personalized
fertility team to help you understand
your results and make a game plan you
get access to a team of fertility nurses
a weekly webinar and their online
community of women just like you that's
like making mini toast like the Facebook
group it's like having that community of
people who are going through the same
things he was probably the most helpful
I mean I don't know cuz I'm not in it
right now but I assume it's one of the
most helpful parts of going through
something as tough as fertility 100%
because like people don't want to talk
about it but talking about it I think
also some people you don't know right
right right
modern fertility is super convenient
they ship the kit to your home you get a
physician reviewed result in a few days
it's very cost efficient at just $159
modern fertility gives you access to
information you need to plan ahead the
same tests are over a thousand dollars
at your doctor's office and you can use
an FSA or an HSA they have a personal
fertility team that you connect
the fertility nurse you join their
weekly webinar participate in their
active online community with women just
like you you get peace of mind because
modern fertility gives you the knowledge
and information you need to make the
best decision all the tests are
conducted in a CLIA certified lab and
monitor fertility esteem of physicians
and clinical advisors lead some of the
nation's top fertility clinics visit
modern fertility dot-com / toasts take
their fertility quiz and get $20 off
your modern fertility test that's modern
fertility calm / toast
- take the fertility quiz and get $20
off modern fertility dot-com / toast
sign on and hopefully get pregnant
next up Pete Davidson has a new woman I
saw Davidson and Margaret quali hold
hands during a Mantic Venice trip she's
like an up-and-coming actress like
people are satisfied she's any
McDowell's daughter and she's the sister
oh my god wait wait Lee Jackie what yes
say it again Andie MacDowell the girl
from all the old lady commercials no and
she's also like in all the hallmark
movies yes she's an icon curly black
hair yes she's always in like an old leg
commercial yes yes oh yeah I'm sure
daughter and sister of Ray need to
remember her my mom made you listen to
her music rainy Wally no it is no rainy
are a ine why if you listen to it you
would remember because she once
performed that I heard and she's so
talented
Oh Rhaenys really pretty they're both
beautiful and then rainy was also in
like one scene of madmen in a fur coat
like I'm happy for Pete Davidson man
this is such an appropriate relationship
it seems I mean not as appropriate as
Kathy David because that will forever be
like the most perfect evening yeah like
really I still found him in Ari no I
definitely don't like that was much
toxic relationship but I feel like if it
can't be Cathy David it can be her
look-alike magret quali whatever he was
oh yeah it is totally her look-alike and
Margaret's not like an up-and-coming
actress in the Venice Film Festival and
so like these are just two artistes yeah
and I'm really happy for him michio like
he definitely went through it
relationship wise and I feel like he was
probably accept did you see that video
of him in Florida like oh my god because
I was recording I didn't see the video
but I read
what he said he said some [ __ ] [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and it's like chill out like
people using their phone like that is
like not a real problem you know what I
mean people recording yeah
really haven't really feel well I would
feel awful but I would not go off like I
don't know I'm I don't have a horse in
this race and I really see both sides
but I kind of feel it and for going off
like no there are very owned and
especially don't film his set because
like that's a rule
across all comedy because why would
anyone ever greet your show but they're
like he's very few moments as a comedian
that warrant you like freaking out the
audience ruining your show and calling
them the artwork the artwork yeah the
very field well membered is definitely
where he crossed like where he lost
everyone but say he hadn't said the art
word maybe these college students need
to be yelled at sure but like I said one
who probably went to the show like
wanting to laugh like and wasn't
recording that you're gonna let that one
person ruin the whole show and like it's
kind of how like in the Chappelle
special like when someone's phone rang
like there's a way to take what's
happening and make it funny not [ __ ]
yell at every agreed but I think he did
he handle it so gracefully because he
was filming for Netflix and that's a
lesson that I've always pretend you're
filming for Netflix no because sometimes
people just need to me like put in their
place in that and that guy like yes
sometimes no should feel shamed at his
like the fact that his phone went off
when they're filming a necklace
especially like honestly I think Dave
Chappelle should have really laid into
him even more know like I thought I
disagree like he's like probably the
babysitter like people's lives and I
don't know like out of 2,000 people who
paid money to come see you because they
like you you're gonna spend all this
time ruining the show yelling at one
person like but it's not all this like
in the dish
it's like one two minutes and like you
it throws you off seems to make it part
of your segment that's not what Pete
Davidson did no at all
I'm the fact that Chappelle like
recovered from it and made it so funny
is like so impressive and I understand
that like not everyone could do that but
I don't know I just think like people
who come to see a comedy show they're
not coming to get gelda and the fact
that someone else is recording like a me
I paid money to be here that's not my
[ __ ] problem oh and it's not funny
you calling me an R word you know ya
know key I didn't see the video was he
yelling at the whole audience literally
it's just like collectively talking
about me to a millennial entitlement
like was it so quiet it was so awkward
and obviously what was said
like the whole thing was spiraling from
someone filming him and someone was
filming him yeah having a breakdown did
he end the show after I did he did and
then like the university released a
statement oh yeah and also keep in mind
like oh this is happening on a college
campus like okay in a comedy club it's
like rough-and-tumble like it's a car
it's a [ __ ] college campus like these
are kids they're not kids they're that's
the problem like they act like kids and
they're not cuz they're treated like
kids they [ __ ] living dorm right so
someone needs to come in yeah yeah like
that maybe not painting that didn't even
have to pay for the show oh they did it
yeah yeah like a lot by those student
groups yeah then the kids probably don't
even have to pay for the show and so um
you know regardless of whatever the
school paid them these kids pay tuition
like in in some way these kids are
responsible for Pete Davidson either I'm
sure they wanted him to come they rally
they got the budget on your phones yes
you're important you rally do you have
the budget I don't know it's like it's
like three well I don't know how many
kids like one kid was on his phone like
yeah I don't know I just I I would hope
for a little bit more gratitude from a
PTA I agree same time what was [ __ ]
university doing inviting Pete Davidson
I think he overreacted so the point was
missed but like I can I think it's so
frustrating there's a point there
there's all intended going to be made
also I think that is Pete Davidson's
like brand of comedy is just like being
that guy that's just gonna yell at
people and you know go ham it because
they cared the First Minister and he's
not super filtered and like this isn't
the first time at this yeah I've seen
this story before me choose without a
car where shout out Mac Miller and like
he literally had to stop the whole show
yeah he's sick and tired of it yeah
maybe it's a new job like maybe stuff
going on door he's like Arianna
that's why SNL is perfect for ya because
there's no hecklers he can like be funny
no one's on the phones because it's
being recorded on TV speaking of
honestly I think he's been hanging out
spit Sebastian Maniscalco cuz it sounds
like they have the same message
speaking of your phone someone's filming
in is better speaking of you know live
comedy shows I'd be remiss if I didn't
tell you guys that I'm heading back on
tour the tour is in full swing next week
we're hitting Austin we're getting
Portland we're in Seattle so many of the
shows it's like such a relief like
walking into these cities with sold-out
shows some of them are not but like most
of them aren't just feel so good but I
think there's still tickets open to LA a
couple
iego we added the second show Chicago
sold-out Seattle sold-out
Tirana sold-out but head over girl with
no job calm and I promise I won't yell
at you or call you the r-word unless you
like really bother me like that girl oh
my god Margo you know don't talk about
yes that girl where were we
I didn't it all blends in but oh my god
crazy [ __ ] girl like came up to the
stage and like gave me a drink and I'm
like it was actually wish I handled it
better in that moment because like I she
was on the claim yesterday that feels
like I was on the plane you know but I
didn't yell at her I just wish I had
something funnier to say yeah I finally
come to you yes came to me literally
yesterday on the plane when I was
thinking this she had said because like
this this couple like came up it's like
I was in a theater like 700 people this
couple came over the margarita and
they're waiting for me at the stage
while I'm like literally delivering a
set and they were waiting there for at
least 5 min I tried to ignore them being
like maybe they'll understand like I'm
[ __ ] busy and they keep just like
standing there waiting for me I'm like
hi right and I literally just see the
segment in the show about how I can't
drink on stage like literally were you
even [ __ ] listening like that was the
most insulting part like not even
listening and I'm like oh thank you so
much I'm like kinda in the middle of
something but I like was just like a
little dismissive and when like they had
good intentions and I just wish I wasn't
like so like Cavalier I would have taken
the drinking be like you know I'm kind
of busy right now I'm like maybe I'll
drink it later thank you like I wish it
wasn't as because they felt really
awkward and like they did like ruin the
show for literally everyone and I hope
they're watching this and knowing like
that was a bad thing to do like I can't
I can't integrate it enough like how bad
it was I do not come up to the stage I'm
[ __ ] busy yeah you're not an R word
but you know [ __ ] off and I was thinking
yesterday how I was shy I'm sure he's
having a Pitt about it too Davidson well
you know what it's actually funny
because he both went through something
similar and it's like we both have come
to the same conclusion were like you
wish that you were more heavy-handed no
no I wish the opposite I think I was too
heavy-handed
I thought you said you were I was too
dismissive like you didn't address it
no like of them like I was just rude
like my joke was rude okay no no okay
where's my good wish I just like I don't
want anyone to feel unwelcome at my show
but like you are unwelcome if you're
coming up to the front of the stage oh
yeah
don't [ __ ] scream things out let me
just make a you know and overwhelming
announce I'm gonna come to your show
have fun get drugged you know
Ardi dance like don't [ __ ] come up to
the stage and don't [ __ ] scream when
I'm like trying to talk that's it got it
very para 11 love and make a wish I wish
that like people just respect me debts
right you know it I think you and Pete
Davidson are actually on the same page
and like he's out here doing like the
heavy heavy lifting and taking I'm sorry
I just like can't even begin to defend
someone to cause a group of people right
now I'm okay and that part is
indefensible and that's where he lost
everyone and that's why he's completely
wrong but I'm just saying before that
like I'm sure and people are writing in
the comments that their other comedian
she won't do college campuses at all
because those kids are out of control I
don't think I ever would after being
asked so many times how to use their
phones like they still use them yeah so
maybe this is just like something like a
issue with this generation that we are a
part of yeah you know like ya know I
actually have to save the toasters have
a ton of respect I don't see a lot of
people on there so exactly button I know
it's like that's where I was when I was
singing and interview with Maxwell and I
was saying I'm like I don't know like
how other people like I have the me the
best fan base like they're so kind their
service back home like for the most part
they're super respectful at shows I
don't have a lot of recording problems
or a lot of just people texting except
in a comedy club in Chicago this girl
was like literally taking of conference
call like right behind me and I learned
was like are you done like she was
literally like on the phone like Larry
with one of her parents like it was so
crazy like step out but yeah other than
that like if that's your biggest issue I
don't think I would ever do a show on a
college campus right well now you know
what good thing I've never been asked
okay then final story a little good
segue from Pete Davidson to Ariana
Grande who was suing forever21 for using
a look-alike model on social media like
a look-alike like a look like I heard
about this officer alleges in a 10
million dollar suit that the retailers
stole her likeness after failing to come
to an endorsement deal
Ariana Grande has filed a lawsuit
against forever 21 and claims at least
10 million dollars in damages after the
fashion retail retailer allegedly hired
a look-alike model for a social media
campaign according to the complaint
filed in California federal court
forever21 contacted Grande's
representatives in anticipation of her
latest album thank you next for the
purpose of an endorsement deal quote
notably the endorsement deal forever21
sought with miss grande centered around
social media marketing including but not
limited to twitter posts instagram posts
and instagram stories grande who asserts
that the market value for her imprint or
even a since single Instagram post is
well into six figures
says negotiations
meant that the deal never came to
fruition because the amount set
forever21 offered to paid for the right
to use miss Grande's name and likeliness
were insufficient for an artist of her
stature
so basically forever21 came up to her
didn't have enough money and then hired
someone who looks just like her looks
just like her to wear like exactly what
she wore in the seven rings video make
the same face and they're like being
Farian Efron day is that the only
picture they're using like are the two
on the right both Ariana yes that's the
inspiration oh that's a bad [ __ ]
argument it's like this is the photo
they posted to their Instagram and then
it's also on their website I think it's
they're using her name and likeness and
it I know it like honestly was her name
Instagram caption um her caption is gee
thanks just bought it oh and what's
really sad actually is this doesn't seem
like a big deal compared to so many
other websites like that make their
living off of having like Philae
Fenner's and fin far - Ian models this
is where they wear exactly what the
person's wearing it's like oh I see this
on you know fashion of a misguided all
the time like Rhys it's a big deal but
no it's it's actually only it's illegal
yeah also hasn't ariana grande's lawyers
and their research and saw that
forever21 is filing for bankruptcy so
they can't really afford to tell me also
true yeah but if they watch big little
Isaac they'll know that filing for
bankruptcy big deal Yankee Renata they
could still take her house [ __ ]
Grenada I love her we're not kind of
name is that like whoever wrote the book
like all the names Annabella
Amma Bella is out of control it's really
actually hard to remember everyone's
name
what's Nicole Kidman's name Celeste
Celeste and then there's Jane Madeline
but like is her name Madeline or
Madeline Madeline Madeline yeah she's so
cute yes she really is and then
mary-louise oh the mom the names are
just like really a mouthful oh sorry uh
shailene Woodley's kids Ziggy Ziggy and
you know who's everywhere Catherine
Newton yeah yes I had totally forgot
that she was playing Reese Witherspoon's
daughter but then she came on and I was
like oh my god it is alie I know Alec I
feel like people know her from
big.little eyes cuz she also went on a
date with one of the new cast members of
the hills Tommy Lee's and Pamela
Anderson's son she went on the episode
know she like just recently was spotted
out with him oh and they refer to her as
big little eyes actress and I'm like no
no it's the society
star honestly the society really affects
like how I think about things that come
everybody's constantly in my dreams even
when we were at saks maha mom's house we
were talking about like her pantry and
how like if we were in the society oh
yeah we were saying if we were in the
society that we would live the longest
because then Zach's mom's pantry is
[ __ ] way act Wow I ate literally
eight pop-tarts the whole weekend like I
didn't stop yeah so like I just feel as
though I'm always thinking about life in
terms of this society right and there's
like a show that makes you think fugly
that's exactly what it is and I even
last thing was having a dream where I
thought I figured out what happened like
in the society that someone was like I
just read a theory I just read a theory
that people are saying that Ali actually
was the one who killed Cassandra I read
that too oh I may be better the kid
admitted it multiple times yeah and I
kind of understand I don't know I don't
know that I'm talking is confusing yeah
yeah but they can't admit it right maybe
he's just like China and even when he
was begging for his life he never said I
didn't do it that's not true that's true
that scene where they have to kill him
is like was really tough to watch yeah
yeah and I just love grizzly yes his
name great great love him so much I
can't even do it and like where was he
during the coup but actually really
loved he was finding farmland you know
but like we needed him and I'm telling
you they're gonna come back in that farm
line that's gonna be gone yeah I agree I
don't think so I think the way that this
world works it's like it is what it is
it's not going to change at all
unfortunately but you know they have
their lighting they have their water and
electricity you think they're dead I
think they're never there in a whole
nother planet sphere yeah another planet
sphere but I don't think you're gonna
see them like be reunited with your
parent may be like when the show if it
ever is no their parents so I could be
like just what do you mean Linda Linda
from Blue Bloods plays Amaro just her
but you know like we would see them
reunited with their siblings we never
got to know them as family people do you
think they can get hello fresh
deliveries to their new address I
couldn't order stuff online no and I
think that is their biggest cross to
bear it's like okay now we have to cook
for ourselves and we don't even have
hello fries right that's so tough
because hellofresh is making
deliciousness a part of your everyday
week you can blake break out of your
dinner rub with hella freshers 20-plus
seasonal chef curated recipes each week
there's something for everyone from
family recipes to cut calories smart and
vegetarian which is
actly what you did right what you guess
I got some enchiladas vegetarian which
is like so crazy I'm making enchiladas
in my house that is so crazy I never
would've expected that for you right but
like hello Frances me give you the
pre-measured ingredients you just
chopped it up they give you easy
directions yeah directions ingredients
like step by step they make it so so
easy and it's super flexible it fits
your lifestyle you can add extra meals
to your weekly order as well as yummy
add-ons like garlic bread and cookie
dough oh my god I'm getting starving
even just reading this ad easily change
your delivery days your food preferences
and skip a week whenever you want so
it's super easy you can get $80 off your
first month of hellofresh if you go to
hellofresh comm slash toast 80 and enter
the code toast 80 so again that's $80
off your first month of hellofresh go to
hellofresh comm slash toast 80 and enter
code toast 88
it's like receiving eight meals free or
you can get $20 off your first four
boxes um it's actually like a hefty code
$80 yeah right dollars $80 premium well
yeah check out hello fresh I'm [ __ ]
starving I'm litter gonna go run home
and make an enchilada cuz I'm so hungry
my stomach
I've been eating just like everything in
sight for the last five days like I woke
up and I didn't do that I know my body's
in shock now I'm like fasting and my
body's like what happened no I woke up
swollen I don't know if it's Herman all
the alcohol or the food like I'm just I
I'm not hungry and I'm by this time I'm
always starving he woke up school I woke
up so I see I have reserves right now
yeah like it's still eating the food
that I ate yesterday yeah I got that
start up for winter I'm good like six
years yeah you can for the society right
excuse me did you just call me that no
but like I was just saying you're like I
have the society watch so [ __ ] PA okay
we're gonna take a quick break Amanda
Stanton should be here any minute go get
a snack go to the bathroom chill out
take a xanax calm down
go do all the go to all those things and
we'll be back in a few minutes at the
manda Stanton if you do have any
questions for a man this Hinton feel
free to drop them in the youtube feed
directly or over on her Instagram page
where we put up a picture of her on
about her book her or her life if she's
dating mom life her resting [ __ ]
you let us know and we'll be back in a
jiffy bye
you
now we are here sitting with author to
the stars
Amanda Stanton actually also best friend
influencer revolve girl around the world
now in designer yes you said mom you've
so many titles what do you prefer now ah
like authors I don't want to take for a
spin
yeah it's terrible you think like it all
today with that blazer yeah I know I
thought like this is very like author
outfit yeah and I also was like I feel
like Jackie O today yeah you look so
cute
thank in your new book now accepting
roses which I feel like has been a long
time coming like I feel like I first
heard about it like a year ago I know I
feel like I've been talking about it
forever cuz they started writing it
almost two years ago whoa longest
process but it's finally out it seems
super excited so it's hating happy feels
like be out meeting is it so vulnerable
feeling like to have all your emotions
out there it's Mary
we're already high yeah they were
already out there no I mean when I was
reading it back I was like some of the
stuff that I wrote I had kind of
forgotten about so you wrote it so long
ago so take a little scary I think I
know it's gonna call you up and be like
I can't believe you said this what's the
most salacious thing in the book uh I
mean there's like there's a few chapters
that I think I don't want to like give
any the joy of it all the Josh Murray
chapter there's a little Robbie and
people be surprised by I use me yes I do
direct it like hey yeah is it hard to
write a book like actually the act of
writing it it's hard but it's like it's
hard to start it this is right you start
you just start then it's like yeah I
think you can't stop picturing journal
yeah I mean you're doing a mini book
tour right yeah he brought you to
Brooklyn and then I go to New Jersey
tomorrow then Chicago Iowa and
Minneapolis oh yeah I've you practiced
your like signature like with a little
heart I just practiced it earlier okay I
need somewhere except to practice I do
the hardest part about being an altar
it's really like having a cute signature
that you're can do like 20,000 times
over yeah I was like I need a stamp yes
but you know that's considered very
inauthentic it's tacky
yeah you know police is pretty
and have the girls read the book no
Reno's are they can read how will do
kids our kids when they learn how to
read kids like Kim's excite are saying
this old I feel like yeah
so you just so five years without
reading as a kid I never thought about
that
yeah and then you start reading
everything do they be like driving
employees must wash yes cuz now I can't
like say I used to like if I didn't say
something bad it would just spell it and
now she's like oh mom I know what you
said oh damn yeah yeah she's getting so
old she's old so she has read the book
she has nothing I'm not letting a read
it ya know I think maybe when she gets
older yeah I'm so excited to read it
me too I love a good bachelor memoir we
haven't had one in so long
yeah it's actually very true you're
filling the gap in the market yeah yeah
we got a lot of questions for you
like taking relationship-wise um and
there's something I have to ask you
about that I just need to know your
opinion on because you have previously
in the past day that Josh Marie
obviously um and Robbie Hayes and the
two of them have found themselves in a
little bit of a pickle when it comes to
Lyndsey chrisley and like a sex tape and
I just wanted allegedly allegedly do you
know Lizzie grisly like what is going on
there I so I don't know Lindsay I knew
they were friends there's actually so
funny because when I got off the show I
remember Josh when he was still living
in Atlanta I was hanging up Lindsay
there was like a photo of that man I was
like who is this girl he's like oh she's
just a friend
sure I'm like interesting um but no I
mean I know they were good friends and I
I don't really don't know anything about
me stay in the alleged sex tape I have
not had no plans do you look I already
sound like a dog camera show here that
makes so much sense told ya Wow another
question we got for you is you're
recently out of a new relationship
relationship an old relationship um also
named Robert Bobby Bobby and we got
should have a lot of questions about
Bobby and asking if he was editing his
eyes in his Instagram pictures to be
more blue I don't think so but he I
think he's as a filter he's like oh this
thing is really blue right he's really
blue eyes so that it wasn't fake no okay
yeah and is it true that he was related
well is related to Ashley Jacobs from
southern charm
they're not really dead
not my mother remember that and I
started so the toasters totally thought
it cuz they also hang out once okay okay
sure your so you record straight they do
not relate that related yeah Wow oh my
god I totally I was convinced that they
were no no way
damn okay well you were just at Ashley
yards wedding yes yes and there are a
lot of people in the comments who like
really ship you and Nick file and
honestly I'm not not one of them and you
also do the hip-hop cast it just seems
like there was a lot of respect in the
room a lot of respect maybe a little
sexual tension no it's so funny because
it keeps one of my good friends and they
just got asked about this in another
podcast of during but hopefully one
that's not as fun as this one
yeah but Nick's like he's been one of my
good friends forever and he's also the
person that I go to for relationship
advice so like when I have a problem in
a relationship I call him and I ask for
his advice I was like I could never date
him because then he would ask for advice
I couldn't do it and then he knows you
too well
he knows me too yeah we're just for good
as friends yeah well maybe you could
take the Tyler seer out and date a model
right maybe I don't know if models are
my thing either I don't know what my
thing is I don't smell bottles or my
fingers anything are you I'm loving it
right yeah yeah yeah it's been fun I
think it is fun
I wouldn't know I've never been single
in my life but I feel like it's fun
yeah it's fun and you just came from a
revolve trip that looked amazing yes we
have to go there or less happy to go
what we're but it's in Canada it's and
you fly into Calgary and it's like a
two-hour drive these damn Lake Louise
it's amazing the water it's very like
fancy it's a fridge yeah it is French
okay so yeah it was beautiful it's so
pretty is my second time going to say
went last year to the yeah it's amazing
yeah yeah we're gonna go you guys should
go we've evolved you guys doing shoes
where you want to go like we got the
language and about the revolt really
yeah so they plan the trips and then
they invite into influence but they have
like X amount of trips per year do you
choose which ones you want to go to or
just ones that fit your schedule or its
predetermined no like you they just they
emailed me about this candor to one
probably three weeks ago so it's kind of
last-minute and then you yeah obviously
get to choose if you go or not they
don't like yeah but yeah
do you love them they're super fun it's
when you're gonna like meet a bunch of
people yeah and you get to go to cool
places which in the most
I think probably I mean Coachella is
obviously really doing that but I was
dying
remember Coachella me laughter like
we're gonna go the after-party we're
just gonna eat yeah we went to
Applebee's we were never to be seen
again and then we went that Applebee's
was amazing hi everybody we saw how many
were there I mean it was so it was about
that I can leave you guys some number to
Applebee's it's [ __ ] bomb and by the
way it's a real full bar so we were
continuing to drink yeah well also
eating beer cheese and mozzarella so he
has big plans big plans I'm gonna be
arguing a bridesmaid for Morin I would
assume or they get married super soon it
feels like it I mean I don't really know
like all of her wedding plans right and
I that is so crazy that she's like
engaged and she just has this whole new
life like you guys started out just like
two young bucks on been hit in season
and like you both have just come so far
like you have full-fledged businesses
she's getting married like how does that
feel just like having watched your whole
life play out in a public over the last
like five years
it's so weird and I was texting her
yesterday I was like it I don't really
think it hit me until the other day when
I got her wedding invitation and I was
like oh like you're actually gonna be a
wife like you're gonna get married like
this is so weird and that yeah that's so
crazy
oh and that's the cutest name ever
Lauren Lane Lauren Lane yeah it was so
cute she's such a little southern belle
that's gonna be so fun I was really
hoping that you guys were gonna have
your about trot party at stagecoach
maybe now when you get married next
you'll have your bachelor at stagecoach
yeah it's not a good idea yeah yeah
hello now everyone's gonna come to say
choice have you been watching bachelor
in paradise
yeah like I feel like now it's hit the
mainstream because you go you might
sleep with like yeah and I think we can
go next yeah okay so I mean we're going
we have so much fun but it's like yeah
it's like very over done now I feel like
yeah are you watching the season of
bachelor parent I watched the first few
episodes and I didn't they've like
brought up stagecoach like 100 to 1000
times so yeah that was like a paid
partnership with stagecoach to get some
marketing guys really working I mean
it's smart yeah stagecoach should let
every bachelor prison go for free and I
totally go in the bathroom we're gonna
get on the batter yeah
shooting work would be good on the
bachelor
good right I would die you should can
you like I feel like she's like she
knows too much about like the behind the
scenes yeah like she wouldn't be able to
take it seriously and I'm sure people
ask you this all the time but like would
you ever go back on paradise no would
you ever be the best read okay so I have
no desire to go back on any dating show
obviously if they came to me and handed
me a contract
I wouldn't feel like yeah I do because
that's like such a special opportunity
yeah like I mean everyone would ya like
to be the Bachelorette lowly's yeah you
would they both like make your own rules
like Emily Maynard did and like she was
able to turn her hometown and let you
live in LA so and like you'd ghettoes be
able to keep all your wardrobe that's
what I would do
yeah yeah yeah totally I mean I would
but I don't like want to write you're
making it out exactly
tell us about Jared and Ashley's wedding
it was really quite beautiful it was so
pretty oh my god her dresses were
amazing
her dress amazing yeah it was super cute
they were both so happy they did so much
fun yeah it was beautiful were there any
like inter bachelor nation hookups of
people who like aren't dating that we
would assume honestly pretty much
everyone there was in a relationship
like every bachelor person that's how
you know you guys are growing up like
yeah then I'm like the single no but you
have your life together you chickens you
began that [ __ ] that yeah it's fine so
no tea any drama honestly no did they
film it Mary I know so it's not gonna be
televised that's so unlike them I know I
think they wanted it to be like a little
more private right yeah it was really
yeah it's when he they didn't know what
to expect cuz Ashley is like so
princessy it's on her dress would be
like good job you know sparkles
everywhere and it wasn't it was like
very like cluttered a big girl again it
was so pretty I thought she's beautiful
I totally agree yeah it was good fun to
watch as someone who wasn't invited you
know yeah yeah sure we need to start so
I'm sure we've done for someone who's
actually invited how fun
thank you so tell us about the book
where can people get it starting today
right yes
so it's officially out so you can buy it
on Amazon it's on Amazon Prime Barnes
and Noble indigo books pretty much any
major book retailer
congratulations I have a good feeling
about it so support Amanda buy the book
go to some of the book tour stops like
you said Brooklyn tonight in New Jersey
tomorrow our tri-state area folk and
maybe if you live in Iowa I don't the
Boise Idaho never enough valuable
toasters or life but if you are moving
anything yeah Des Moines thank you yeah
thank you so much for being here good
luck on the book congratulations on the
book we love you follow me on Instagram
it's very confusing there's two ends at
the end but there's not two ends in your
name well I need to fix it and you jus
yeah I was actually saying that when we
tagged you like how how is that not
happened yet so I found the girl that's
at in my understanding and I messaged
her and I was like can I give you $300
for my name she just read it and never
answered oh I'm doing Amanda underscore
Stanton with two N's why can't you just
do a man to underscore skin with one
that someone has that tail shut up but I
just want like Amanda Stanton just yeah
you need a Damaris mind can we all need
to bombard her yeah oh my that is
hilarious do charset kins run their own
Instagram I run it idea yeah but Ken's
actually has a secret private Instagram
that's really sad she has a pin stuff
yeah no no it's like it's her own
personal but I never post it just
because it's private but he follows her
friends from school and I supervise it
that is M Q it
she the boyfriend no you should be
ashamed boys yet or not yeah so she has
a group at school and they called
themselves the bossy Girls Club and they
walk around and they like well
accidentally like bump into a boy and be
like whoa sorry I didn't see you when we
were in high school
I'm middle school I'm just like I am
boys but okay sorry Rach nothing all I
want to do is put like a secret camera
on them when they go to school so you
see like how they act with their friends
sorry sorry thank you guys so much for
watching the morning toast if you want a
Florida a Caribbean a Bahamian toaster
we hope you are doing okay weathering
the storm hopefully watching the trust's
making you feel better but maybe not
maybe it's making you feel worse I don't
know um thank you for listening to the
morning toast Milania morning show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available in the
podcast app anywhere podcasts can be
found that's podcast iTunes Spotify
stitcher all the places subscribe that
leave a five star review about how I
made some yarn how our guests are so
funny and cool I'm like we are both
likes that's gonna a beautiful thank you
so much we'll see you tomorrow have a
great day
you